welcome to this video playing Green
Haven from the US um maybe maybe do
something else the Trump hmm yeah I know
you can take but maybe I can keep the
bishop for a moment how very active
maybe if I take now G takes ok now let's
open up the center after giving up the
the bishop curves for this kind of
weaknesses maybe you should try to play
concretely in the center after his c5
it's it's gone that idea to to do
anything anything slow I mean it's just
just not in the position anymore let's
just play for them for the development
sure I guess he needs to take now on c4
I mean e6 looks really crazy ok so just
Knight f3 now can you go oh gee for our
maybe d5 gap not not clear if I go d5
here I can do that it's not entirely bad
but it's got 95 Bishop c4 I'm not sure
about that ok let's develop
yeah Bishop g4 looks normal to me
yeah what what now md5 95
maybe it should be to a smooth actually
Bishop takes Bishop takes an ITEX but
should be seven is quite good yeah maybe
maybe intending d5 actually I but maybe
just e 6 mm just e6 okay
yeah it still feels some I should be ok
here but it's not like I can refute what
he what he was doing I'll get anything
anything great going ok why is he not
taking ok maybe you can you can really
do something else but ok let's say night
before I just takes you for ok that move
194 isn't this isn't this quite good
getting this pressure against the center
on I'd f5 is just one move 96 probably
not but this is just just good isn't
that he takes a 5d take c6 looks like
looks like a thread oh that's turned out
really nicely and you cannot castle of
course just them yeah I can take just
imagine just take now look you one ok so
sure maybe just 95 and this is just a
good such a good position 95 come on
long castles s-97 one of the Knights
winning the Queen I could play Queen age
five I'm sorry just green age five and
Queen age six was already completely
killing well okay this is this is also
quite good
came some night f 6 cm 197 and then
Queen e6 it's also probably completely
decisive
Janet's let's do that it it should be a
win
and maybe you can actually click into f7
yeah as usual I make life very tough on
myself was entirely unnecessary just
queen age five a couple of moves earlier
and it's already completely completely
curtains okay now on cam rook g8 I've
got Queen h5 should so be win a
non-threatening night c7 just getting
the night back in to claim as Queen c7
is always losing ticket to Queenie six
and now maybe it's still a win wait two
three okay let's prevent h3
I cannot play a 3m it's unbelievable
check well
time warning don't check see you when I
simply don't check check check
I don't think he can play for win check
game drawn I'm such an idiot really
sometimes I mean yeah I'm okay somebody
no no comment I mean this is probably a
major yeah just a simple do you want it
shang great just great okay this was
totally winning this is probably also
totally winning but check I mean what
the heck 96cm okay yeah it's it's really
idiotic completely idiotic yeah now i
don't know maybe 97's to Lavinia 97's
sterling I have Queenie 6 of course
which I completely failed to see and
hear it's a chain justice Jack strong
yeah sometimes sometimes i'm just
playing like an idiot and I mean I mean
how bad this Knight a5 I mean how could
you ever consider this move why put it
on the board on the edge of the board no
way back whatever and 94 is so obviously
terrible for black and then you don't
know when yeah this is the worst of it
really amazing yeah of course them not
not I mean I immediately saw it
immediately saw but this looks like such
an attractive move but the Queen age 5
is of course so much simpler wow I'm
really rusty okay thanks for watching